[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis
schön dass sie dabei sind was den sport
angeht hätte katja stresow auf dem
laufenden einen schönen guten abend
unsere großen themen heute
nach wochenlanger belagerung mehr als
260 ukrainische kämpfer verlassener
stahlwerke mario pohl und gehen in
russische gefangenschaft
poker um nato-erweiterung schweden und
finnland wollen den beitritt zum
verteidigungsbündnis die türkei aber
blockiert
und fahren mit autopilot auf deutschen
straßen werden bald selbstfahrender
autos unterwegs sein allerdings erstmal
nur bei stockendem verkehr
es ist die letzte verteidigungsstellung
der ukrainischen truppen im strategisch
wichtigen mariupol jetzt haben sich
hunderte verletzte kämpfer aus dem
umkämpften also stahlwerk ergeben die
verschanzen soldaten waren zu einem
sinnbild geworden für den widerstand
gegen die russischen truppen die
kontrolle über die weitgehend zerstörte
hafenstadt haben christoph des 3
in diesem moment werden aus kämpfern des
asaf regiments kriegsgefangene über fünf
wochen hatten sie im stahlwerk die
stellung gehalten zuletzt fast ohne
trinkwasser
bildmaterial vom russischen
verteidigungsministerium das von dessen
sprecher kommentiert wird
in den letzten 24 stunden haben 265
kämpfer die waffen niedergelegt und sich
ergeben darunter 51 schwer verwundete
weiter sagt er die verletzten seien in
ein krankenhaus in nova aus gebracht
worden die anderen so heißt es nach urin
fk beide orte liegen im russisch
besetzten gebiet
waffen niedergelegt sich ergeben die
ukrainische seite klingt anders von
einer evakuierung ist da die rede davon
dass die verteidiger von mario pohl ihre
mission erfüllt hätten dank ihnen habe
man wichtige zeit gewonnen und so die
eigenen truppen neu gruppieren können
jetzt werde an einem austausch prozess
für die soldaten gearbeitet
wir hoffen dass wir die leben unserer
jungs retten können ich möchte
unterstreichen dass die ukraine ihre
helden leben braucht das ist unser
prinzip am nachmittag dann schildert in
moskau parlamentspräsident wolodimir
eine sicht der dinge das sei ein
kriegsverbrecher und sie müssten vor
gericht ein abgeordneter fordert sogar
die todesstrafe
gleichzeitig veröffentlichen
pro-russische kämpfer material das sie
auf patrouillen mario pohl zeigen soll
angeblich von heute einer von ihnen
umreißt was für sie dort noch zu tun ist
hier sind wir direkt vor dem stahlwerk
wir sollen aufräumen alles besetzen den
feind eliminieren diese nazis
rund 600 männer vom nationalistischen
asaf regiment sollen sich noch
verschanzt halten die 265 jetzt
evakuierten haben zwar die hölle in den
kellern hinter sich ihre zukunft aber
scheint mehr als ungewiss
und in der ukraine ist für uns dara
hassanzadeh ja wie wahrscheinlich ist
denn ein schneller gefangenenaustausch
ein schneller gefangenenaustausch ist
wirklich äußerst schwierig zum einen hat
man die technische seite man muss die
frontlinie überqueren und es fehlt an
vertrauen auf beiden seiten die
ukrainische seite und viele politiker
haben es ja deutlich gemacht sind
durchaus bereit teile auf die forderung
russlands einzugehen und seien sie noch
so hoch denn es handelt sich bei diesen
soldaten ja um die helden von mario pohl
die ganz lange widerstand geleistet
haben das wiederum weiß natürlich auch
die russische seite und ihrer erzählung
der großen eroberung eines erfolges in
mario pohl können sie natürlich jetzt
mit dem vorführen dieser gefangenen
ausspielen eine prognose jetzt zu wagen
ist schwierig bis unmöglich aber die
verhandlungen sind in vollem gange und
da die tatsache dass von der
ukrainischen seite so gut wie nichts
nach außen trinkt ist ein zeichen dafür
aus der ukraine dara hassanzadeh danke
für diese einschätzung
der russische einmarsch in die ukraine
ist für finnland und schweden ein
alarmsignal
sie wollen jetzt so schnell wie möglich
in die nato vor wenigen stunden wurde in
finnland offiziell der beitritt am tag
unterzeichnet beide länder wollen ihre
anträge morgen gemeinsam bei der
militärallianz einreichen russland
kündigte bereits an auf die erweiterung
zu reagieren anne gellinek über den
historischen schritt
nun also auch schweden in stockholm
unterschreibt außenministerin an linde
feierlich und vor kameras den
beitrittsantrag für die nato
es ist ein bedeutsamer ein sehr ernster
moment und es fühlt sich so an als ob
wir das tun von dem wir denken dass es
das beste für schweren ist
damit ist es offiziell schweden und
finnland streben nach jahrzehnten der
neutralität in die nato um schutz vor
russland zu suchen das militärbündnis
empfängt sie mit offenen armen denn von
beiden ländern würde die allianz
erheblich profitieren
finnland hat der direkten grenze zu
russland wegen nie bei der armee gespart
und verfügt im kriegsfall über
185.000 soldaten plus 238 tausend
reservisten
schweden besitzt eine kleinere armee
bringt aber moderne u boote und gut
ausgestattete kampfflugzeuge mit ein
doch es gibt noch ein problem
30 nato mitgliedsländer müssen zustimmen
eins davon die türkei ist dagegen
präsident erdogan wirft schweden und
finnland vor kurdische separatisten zu
unterstützen die die türkei als
terroristen betrachtet
wie können wir ihnen trauen schweden ist
eine brutstätte für terrororganisationen
die nato versucht den konflikt
herunterzuspielen und dabei
herauszufinden was erdogan wirklich will
der deutsche kanzler optimistisch ich
bin so zuversichtlich wie der nato
generalsekretär dass das auch schnell
und zügig gelingen wird mit der
unterstützung aller länder auch der
türkei als nato-mitglied
es wäre ein express beitritt schon im
herbst könnten finnland und schweden
nato-mitglieder sein wenn die türkei
einlenkt
wenn die türkei einlenkt florian hahn
was steckt hinter der drohung erdogan ja
das ist die frage die man sich in vielen
anderen nato städten ebenfalls stellt
offiziell argumentiert erdogan ja mit
diesem vorwurf der vermeintlichen
unterstützung durch die durch die
schweden und finnland an die pkk man
hält dass er bei den vielen anderen
staaten nur für einen vorwand viel eher
dürfte es erdogan gehen um
rüstungslieferungen an sein land vor
allem um lieferungen von us-kampfjets
die ankara gerne hätte aber seit 2009 10
nicht mehr bekommt jetzt hat er da eben
einen hebel entdeckt dann ziemlich
mächtigen sogar denn das veto eines
einzigen staates kann ja diesen ort
erweiterung blockieren und das wäre eine
wirklich dramatische schwächung der nato
in dieser entscheidenden phase das heißt
in den nächsten tagen jetzt stören
dürfte der druck auf ankara enorm
steigen und auch jetzt schon dürfte der
verhandlungspause bereits eröffnet sein
noch aber gibt man sich im kreise der
nato optimistisch dass diese krise sich
noch bei legen lässt danke florian
machtspiele in der nato darüber sprechen
wir auch ab 19.30 bei zdf heute live mit
einem türkei expertin sie können
mitdiskutieren in der zdf- heute- app
und auf unseren social media kanälen
wegen des ukraine kriegs sind die preise
etwa für weizen so hoch wie nie unicef
warnt für kinder könnte das tödliche
folgen haben schon jetzt sterben dem
kinderhilfswerk zufolge jährlich mehr
als eine million kinder weltweit an
mangelernährung in den kommenden monaten
könnten hunderttausende dazu kommen man
rechne damit dass auch medizinische
spezialnahrung deutlich teurer werde
nach unicef schätzungen sind etwa 45
millionen kinder unter fünf jahren akut
mangelernährt
nach den tödlichen schüssen buffalo
haben us präsident joe biden und seine
frau jill der opfer gedacht an einer
improvisierten gedenkstätte legten sie
blumen nieder biden bezeichnete die tat
als inländischen terrorismus die
nationalsozialistische idee einer
angeblichen weißen vorherrschaft habe in
den usa keinen platz am samstag hatte
ein 18-jähriger 13 menschen erschossen
davon elf schwarze den ermittlern
zufolge war die tat rassistisch
motiviert
nach deutschland die neue
missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung kerstin klaus fordert
ein kompetenzzentrum forschung das
regelmäßig verlässliche zahlen zu fällen
sexualisierter gewalt vorlegen solle
zudem kündigte sie an die vernetzung
zwischen bund ländern und kommunen
verbessern zu wollen da der schutz von
kindern immer vor ort anfange
als reisende kennen wir das in vielen
deutschen städten kommt bei der
hotelrechnung noch mal was oben drauf
jetzt könnte es so eine bettensteuer
bald noch mehr städten geben denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat sie heute
für verfassungsgemäß erklärt und damit
die klage von hoteliers ab gewesen sie
halten den aufwand für nicht zumutbar
und sind über die entscheidung nicht
erfreut christoph schneider
astrid späth führt gemeinsam mit ihrem
mann ein vier-sterne-hotel in freiburg
die in der stadt erhobene bettensteuer
auf private übernachtungen aber die
stört astrid späth
es ist eine ganz um gerechte sache weil
eine berufsgruppe wird da zur kasse
gebeten und das geld fließt in den
stadtsäckel also wird nicht ist nicht
zweckgebunden für tourismus die
bettensteuer hierzulande wird sie
bislang von gut 50 städten landauf
landab erhoben ob die in freiburg 5
prozent vom nettopreis der übernachtung
oder in frankfurt am main zwei euro pro
person und tag fällig werden die steuer
spült nicht zweckgebundene millionen in
manch klamme kommunale kasse dresden
nahm damit 2018 rund 10 millionen euro
ein ungerecht finden das hotel betreiber
wie die schweiz doch das
bundesverfassungsgericht weist auch ihre
verfassungsbeschwerden nun zurück die
bettensteuer belaste die betroffenen
hotels nicht übermäßig und sei eine
eigene zulässige steuer so die
richterinnen und richter enttäuschung
beim hotel- und gaststättenverband
dehoga die branche ist mega hart
getroffen und ich appelliere an die
kommunen diese entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts jetzt nicht
als ermunterung zu sehen der deutsche
städtetag sieht in der entscheidung
freibrief die städte gehen
verantwortungsbewusst mit der
bettensteuer um wie mit jeder anderen
steuer da wird sich nichts dran
verändern also ist nicht zu befürchten
dass jetzt die hotels drangsaliert
werden durch überzogene bettensteuern
das ist glaube ich quatsch aber gut
möglich ist es dass jetzt noch weitere
städte und kommunen über eine
bettensteuer nachdenken
versprochen hat die autoindustrie das
seit langem ein auto das wirklich selber
fährt während die passagiere tun können
was sie wollen level 5 nennen das die
hersteller doch so weit sind sie noch
lange nicht zwar gibt es schon
assistenzsysteme die auch für das
autonome fahren wichtig sind sie können
wie hier das tempo und den abstand
kontrollieren und immer unter den
wachsamen augen des fahrers selbst
bremsen oder die spur halten automatisch
überholen und selbst einpacken
jetzt wird ein weiterer schritt realität
das auto darf bei bestimmten
verkehrslagen tatsächlich autonom fahren
auf allen deutschen autobahnen
immerhin level 3 wie das funktioniert
zeigt eva schiller
wir machen uns auf die suche nach stau
oder stockendem verkehr
denn nur dann darf das auto bislang die
kontrolle übernehmen auf der autobahn
bis maximal 60 km/h
jetzt können meine hände weg vom steuer
film gucken lesen sms-schreiben fast
alles erlaubt der fahrer darf nicht
laufen und muss so ein zirka zehn
sekunden wieder die aufgabe übernehmen
das level 3 system wird nicht in der
baustelle oder bei ungünstigen
umgebungsbedingungen wie zb schneeregen
oder hinterland deutschland ist das
erste land der welt das fahrzeugen per
gesetz erlaubt selbst zu fahren mercedes
ist der erste hersteller der die
voraussetzungen für hoch automatisierte
sogenanntes level 3 fahren erfüllt das
besondere es haftet nicht der fahrer
sondern der hersteller das ist zum
ersten mal in der automobilgeschichte
dass so etwas passiert und es ein
wirklich dramatischer übergang in der
haftung hier und auch in der
verantwortung
ein laserscanner im fahrzeug neben
kameras radaren also insofern eine menge
technik ist dazu notwendig um das
darzustellen in den usa experimentieren
tesla google und co zwar schon mit
autonomen fahr funktionen sie sind aber
bislang nur zu testzwecken erlaubt
deutschland ist jetzt vorreiter vorerst
können davon ausgehen dass sowohl
europäische als auch amerikanische als
auch asiatische wettbewerber jetzt sehr
sehr schnell auch mit einer ähnlichen
funktion kommen werden und dann ist es
für kunden nutzen wichtig dass die
geschwindigkeit steigt dass man das
system auch nachts und nutzen kann der
stau geht in eine baustelle über die
hände müssen wieder ans lenkrad über
130000 euro kostet die luxuslimousine im
spätsommer könnten die ersten autonomen
autos durch deutsche staus rollen
nun rollen wir nach cannes südfrankreich
wo zur stunde das wohl bedeutendste
filmfestival der welt startet zum 75 mal
ein dreivierteljahrhundert großes kino
oder korsett und klar die stars kam auch
romy schneider im cabriolet grace kelly
mit dem boot und alfred hitchcock
fahrrad viele hollywood gäste unter
mittelmeer palm und manche zeiten auch
deutschsprachige ganz unterschiedlichen
qualitäten auch wenn der ukraine krieg
vieles überschattet kann wird er noch
strahlen von dort an arendt wir sagen
film ab
der glanz kehrt zurück an die korsett
der rote teppich ausgerollt für die
stars die zu stunde die stufen zu
festspielhaus erklimmen knapp zwei
wochen steht kann im zeichen des kinos
und ein preisträger ist schon ausgemacht
forest whitaker erhält die ähren palme
vor 34 jahren war er zum ersten mal in
cannes
du tust das festival hat mich damals als
künstler in der ganzen welt bekannt
gemacht und mir respekt eingebracht
spielen das hat mich sehr berührt auf
dem diesjährigen programm
hollywood-streifen arthouse-filme
politische dokumentationen promi fans
freuen sich unter anderem auf tom der
seine fortsetzung von top gun
präsentieren wird das festival eine
bühne für künstler aller genres
doch schon auf den eröffnungsfilm fällt
der schatten des krieges
ließ diese zombie komödie zunächst dann
wurde der buchstabe zum russischen
propaganda symbol und alt titel
unmöglich und so läuft der film heute
abend unter dem namen coupé
die kinowelt trifft sich wieder an der
côte d'azur zu angestammten zeit im
frühsommer und alles könnte so sein wie
vor der pandemie doch natürlich ist
nichts wie immer so lange krieg in der
ukraine herrscht russische und
ukrainische filmemacher werden beim
festival vertreten sein sie stehen
bereits jetzt im fokus im wettbewerb um
die goldene palme laufen 21 produktionen
sie wird ende nächster woche vergeben
das filmfest hat schon begonnen das
europa-league-finale darauf warten noch
die fußball fans ganz gespannt und kann
es kaum abwarten eigentlich stündlich
steigt ich war absolut morgen abend
frankfurt gegen glasgow nicht nur die
frankfurter sprechen vom
jahrhundertspiel mehr als 100.000 ticket
anfragen von eintracht-fans hat es für
das finale gegen die rangers gegeben
10.000 hat jeder verein zumindest
offiziell bekommen es könnte ein
hitziges spiel werden morgen abend in
sevilla beim abschlusstraining der
eintracht werden heute deutlich mehr als
30 grad gemessen frankfurts trainer
oliver glasner weiß um den druck der
hitze und mehr noch um den der
übergroßen erwartungen und stapelt
deshalb erstmal tief wurde mir auch
zugetragen dass ich eben nach ernst
happel der zweite österreichische
trainer werde ein internationales finale
gewonnen hat ist ja nice to have aber
ändert mein leben nicht wirklich
spätestens nach dem sensationellen 3 2
erfolg im viertelfinale beim fc
barcelona haben sich die frankfurter zu
einer internationalen fußball adresse
gemacht
auch morgen werden in zivil wieder mehr
als 30 grad gemessen vielleicht ein
kleiner vorteil für die eintracht
gegenüber den schotten aus dem deutlich
kühleren glasgow
der fußball-bundesligist tsg hoffenheim
hat sich von trainer sebastian hoeneß
getrennt damit reagieren die
hoffenheimer auf die schwache saison
rückrunde die kraichgauer wurden nur
tabellen-neunter verpassten damit einen
platz im internationalen fußball nach
zuletzt neun sieglosen spielen ein
nachfolger wurde noch nicht bekannt
gegeben
bei der eishockey wm in finnland hat das
deutsche team sein viertes
vorrundenspiel gewonnen gegen frankreich
musste das team von trainer toni söder
heute aber hart arbeiten für den 3 2
endstand
die entscheidung in der 46 minute
besorgte deutsche meister spieler marc
noebels auf leo pföderl von den eisbären
berlin es ist ein knapper pflichtsieg
gegen frankreich die viertelfinal
ambitionen hängen aber auch an der
verletzung von nhl torjäger tim stützle
er schied im ersten drittel aus weitere
turnier einsätze sind noch nicht
ausgeschlossen
so kreative für unsere erste sturmreihe
an
wir können nur hoffen dass es nicht so
schlimm ist dass er beim nächsten mal
wieder dabei ist nach drei spiele in
vier tagen hat das team jetzt pause bis
zur begegnung mit dänemark am donnerstag
lange hat er mit sich gerungen heute nun
hat rodler johannes ludwig sein
karriereende bekanntgegeben
der 36 jährige feierte vor gut drei
monaten seinen größten erfolg als er in
peking olympiasieger im einzel und im
teamwettbewerb wurde 30 jahre auf
kurvenreichen hat er gesagt
hat ja jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
normalerweise ist es sicher nicht das
verkehrsmittel ihrer majestät heute aber
begab sich die britische queen elizabeth
ii zweite in einem londoner
u-bahn-station überraschend und gut
gelaunt nahm sie an der einweihung einer
neue linie am bahnhof paddington teilen
wir zu ehren heißt sie elisabeth seien
wegen gesundheitlicher probleme hatte
die queen zuletzt mehrere offizielle
termine abgesagt
morgen wird ein sommerlich warm ein tag
mit viel sonne und fast ohne gewitter
mehr zu dieser schönen wetter nach ich
gleich von katja honnefer das heute
schon eine christian sievers sehen sie
um 21 45 einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend das tief über dem atlantik
kurbel die warme und feuchte luft aus
südwesteuropa heran gestern gab es
kräftige gewitter und einzelne gewitter
waren auch heute unterwegs zb in
magdeburg aus den resten des gewitters
hat sich hier ein kleines tief
entwickelt das inzwischen aber weiter
nach südosten abgezogen ist die reste
der gewitter trennten aber doch am
nachmittag die 18 grad an der
ostseeküste von 28 grad am oberrhein
jetzt danach bleibt es bei diesem großen
gefälle bei den temperaturen bis auf 7
grad sinken die werte auf rügen bis auf
17 grad am niederrhein dazu ist es in
norddeutschland etwas stärker bewölkt es
kann vielleicht auch noch mal ein paar
spritzer regen geben am anfang der nacht
vier wird das nicht werden im süden ist
es klare bildet sich auch mal nebel und
morgen gibt es viel sonnenschein und
über den mittelgebirgen auch mal ein
paar kleine harmlose quellwolken
allenfalls im emsland kann es am
abendmahl für ein gewitter reichen
vielleicht sehen sie aber auch nur
fernes wetterleuchten und auch morgen
bleibt es bei dem west ost gefälle bei
den temperaturen wird es im westen und
im südwesten mit 30 bis 31 grad hier im
nordosten ist es bei 21 bis 25 grad
etwas angenehmer der donnerstag bringt
uns dann schwül warme gewitter luft von
westen das werden unwetter und die
weiten sich am freitag in richtung osten
aus und nahmen